INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So in today's lecture,
as you can see,
we're going to be talking about
machine learning in the cloud.
This is probably the topic
I'm most excited to get to.
I, kind of, left
it for the end both
because I think it makes
the most sense at the end,
but also because I wanted to
be like my last main module,
we cover.
We may have some time
for some special topics,
but for the most part, I
wanted to leave this to the end
because this is
really where we start
seeing the huge value of what
we're doing in the cloud.
Or at least for me, this is
where I start to see this.
It's also how I first started
to interact with the cloud.
You know, as far
as history goes,
with my background, at
least, I was working
as a data scientist
working on these, you know,
real world problems.
And as the scales of-- or
the size of our data sets
continue to increase, it became
kind of prohibitively expensive
for us to keep having
bigger and bigger laptops
that we were working
on in our office.
And so we did have
servers at our office,
but then taking that to the
next level, at some point
we'd exceed those
capacity, and we
had to keep building
more servers
and maintaining those servers.
And so, you know, our big move,
at least when I was at Carvana,
was when we decided
to say, hey, let's
take a lot of what
we're doing now,
and let's push it up
to the cloud, right.
So that's where we first
started to leverage redshift,
as I talked about
before, and then also
really expand our capacity.
And ever since then,
I mean, every job
I've been in, in the
data science world,
at least we've leveraged the
cloud in some way or another,
right.
Even if it's just a matter of,
you know, using EC2 instances.
So I can spin up a big computer
with a GPU and everything
on board and we'll
talk plenty about that.
But that has been really my
personal tie to Cloud computing,
right.
So, you know, again,
I'm hoping that this
will be a little bit more
coherent than anything
up to this point, though.
I'm hoping that you've been
enjoying at least the topics
we've covered so far.
But this is the one that I do
feel a little bit of confidence
in, right.
I guess that's never too good
when you go on overconfident.
But what I want to talk
about today at least,
is just introducing
why that exists, right.
First off, what machine
learning is, right.
I'm going to hopefully give
you some good vocabulary
to discuss and talk
about these things.
Maybe also make a pitch for
some of my other courses.
I'll talk about those
throughout as we
go through this of
what those offer
as they're more dedicated
towards machine learning.
But I want you to at
least have the vocabulary
to understand what somebody
is talking about when
they say machine learning.
So it's not just this magic
black box that exists out there.
So let's dive into it
and just get into it.
And please, if you ever have
any questions that come up,
come talk to me about it.
I'm again always excited
to talk about this topic.
So I'll slide myself
out of the way now.
Let's go full screen.
And so right away I'm
already in the way.
Let's just do like right here.
So, you know, this slide
is really just motivated
to show you at least how
I define machine learning,
and also how that relates
to artificial intelligence.
I want to get this out of the
way right away or at the start.
There's a lot of hype
around the concept
of artificial intelligence.
And as an avid sci-fi
fan, I am all here for it.
I love the idea of
artificial intelligence.
I think it's, you know,
there's so many cool things
that come out of it.
I mean, there's
some things we'll
need to consider as far as the
biases and whatnot associated
with it but from just
purely conceptual level,
I think it's a really fun idea.
But practically
speaking, I don't
think what we're
doing today falls
into how we view
artificial intelligence.
So I kind of drawn this
here as a Venn diagram,
and arguably they
should overlap some.
I was being a bit harsh
probably when I made this.
But I really view
artificial intelligence
as kind of falling
into two buckets.
So there's artificial
general intelligence,
that is sci-fi level.
You know, when I'm watching a
movie, they're talking about AI.
That's what we're
talking about, right.
That is a completely sentient,
intelligent being robot
whatever it is.
Everything we do
today, if you want
to call it artificial
intelligence,
I think at best you
can say it falls
under the sphere of artificial
narrow intelligence.
And I say narrow
because we're building
these tools, these
models that are
designed to solve, kind of,
a narrow channel of problems.
We as humans have to define
the task very explicitly.
We have to provide the data
necessary for the task,
or at least the
sensors such that it
can understand its environment.
We'll talk about what those are.
But, you know, this
narrow intelligence,
it doesn't breach
beyond that, right.
It can't just all of a
sudden go out and decide
it wants to do something else.
I built a robot to help
me farm more efficiently
or an artificial intelligence to
help me farm more efficiently.
It can't all of a
sudden then pivot
and decide it wants to
go become an artist.
It would only be able to do
the task I have defined to it.
And that's everything
we've done today, right.
We have not done anything
that breaches beyond that.
There does not exist in
artificial intelligence
at that scale.
And so because of that,
I want to keep our focus
more on what is
actually happening,
because I think there's
really cool things that we're
doing right.
Again, my whole
career has so far
has been based on this concept.
So the bottom diagram here
shows this a bit better
of what actually
is happening there.
This is the narrow
intelligence world.
And I'll also say, as far
as these Venn diagrams go,
everything we're going
to talk about today is
falling under the machine
learning bucket writ large.
There's other stuff, you
know, rule-based methods
that could probably fall
into the artificial narrow
intelligence band.
And then within
machine learning,
there's also this
realm of deep learning.
And we'll clarify
why that's different
and why people care
about this so much today.
But again, all of it still
is falling under the machine
learning bucket.
At a high level,
though, when we're
talking about machine
learning, we're
usually talking about
something like this,
a situation like this, where we
have some, sort of, input data
and there's some, sort of,
label associated with it, right.
I have pictures
of cats and dogs,
and I know which ones of
those are cats and dogs.
I put those into my
black box, right.
We've designated this
as a Black box for now.
And then its job is
to learn a mapping.
And when I say mapping, you can
think of that as a function,
right.
Some input produces some
sort of output, right.
If I say y equals mx
plus b and I plug-in--
and I have an M and B there,
and I plug-in some input data x,
I produce a y.
That's a mapping
between x and y now.
And that's exactly
what I'm hoping
to do with these machine
learning algorithms.
I want them to be more
complex mappings such
that now if I have a
new observation, right,
a new picture of an animal,
I don't know which it is.
I put it through my
mapping, my function,
and it says, OK, well,
given this image,
I predict that it is a dog or
I predict that it is a cat.
This is what we're doing.
And we're using all
of the labeled data
to learn this pattern, to
learn this mapping, OK.
Now, within that bucket, though,
there's kind of two camps.
So we have supervised
learning on one side
and unsupervised learning
on the other side.
What I just described to you
was mostly supervised learning.
Supervised learning
is exactly that.
It's saying I have some sort
of labels associated with it.
So if I want to
predict your salary,
given how many years
you went to school,
that's something where
I'd be using supervised
learning because I could
look at how many years
previous people went to school,
and what their salaries were,
right.
Their starting
salaries, let's say.
Or if I'm doing predictive
text, right, I'm using my phone
and I'm typing in text
message to a friend,
and it suggests the
next word to me.
That's a supervised learning
problem, or better yet,
a supervised learning model.
When I train one
of these things,
they become referred
to as models.
And so in that sense, I could
train this model to say,
OK, well, let's look at
all of previous text data,
maybe every text
message I've ever sent
and let's say how often did easy
follow the phrase this class is.
And it's going to say, OK, well,
that's the most common mapping,
right.
That's the most
common occurrence
or something similar to that has
happened more often than not.
And therefore, I will
suggest the word easy
when I provide as input.
This class is, OK.
So again, it's learning
that mapping because it's
seen examples, it's
seen labeled examples
or as I described to you,
recognizing what's in an image,
right.
Saying, OK, well, this
is a cat, this is a dog.
That's the task they're.
Unsupervised learning is kind
of a different beast altogether.
Unsupervised learning is
saying, OK, well, maybe we just
have a bunch of images or
maybe we have, I don't know,
you know, a bunch of salary
data about our employees
or characteristic
about our employees,
but we don't know necessarily
what we're trying to predict
or maybe we're not even
trying to predict anything.
Maybe I have a
bunch of customers
that come to my store
and buy products,
and I have-- you know, they
use their shoppers cart.
So I get a bunch of information
about what they typically buy.
And then I could say,
OK, well, my goal
now is to identify which groups
of people are like each other
because maybe
that's how I'm going
to send them ads or whatnot.
And so I could use
unsupervised learning to say,
OK, well, let's identify-- let's
try to automatically identify
clusters, right.
Natural groupings where
certain people are more
like each other than others.
So that would fall under the
bucket of unsupervised learning.
So again, we have machine
learning, and within machine
learning, you, kind of, fall
into supervised or unsupervised
learning, OK.
Then let's now
imagine that we've
fallen into the bucket
of supervised learning,
machine learning, supervised
learning, unsupervised learning.
Let's go down the
supervised learning path.
And now within that, there's
another question I have to ask.
Is my task a regression task
or is it a classification task?
So in regression we're saying,
OK, well, we're taking--
or we're trying to predict
some sort of continuous output,
right.
So again, my predictor
variable maybe
is something like,
well, how many years
would that person in school.
My response variable,
that's something that's,
kind of, the outcome, right.
My response variable
is the starting salary.
So that's a
continuous prediction.
So my best thing I can hope to
do is fit some sort of function
to it.
Maybe it's a line, maybe it's
some sort of squiggly line,
maybe it's a parabola,
whatever it is,
but it's to fit some
sort of function
to it such that
on average, things
are closest to this function
that I've found, right.
In this case, this line.
I want to minimize the distance
to all the points using
just a single line.
Because what that does
is it says, OK, well now
I have a simplified
representation
of this relationship between
years of education and salary
and everything else
around that I'm assuming
is just noise, right.
There's going to be
some above, some below.
But for the most
part, it's just noise.
On the classification
side, that's
more of what I was
talking about of saying,
well, maybe it falls into
one of two groups, right.
Maybe it's cats, maybe
it's dogs, maybe it's
survival or not survival.
It could be any
number of things.
It could be multiple
labels, too.
It could be that something
could be one of 1,000 different
categories.
Maybe I have 1,000 different
types of things that could
appear in my images.
And so therefore, I have
technically 1,000 different
classes that it could fall into.
And you can kind of
visually think about this
as like, well, it's kind of
like the clustering thing
where points fall
closer together.
But in the
unsupervised learning,
I don't necessarily know it.
I mean, here I showed
you know blue and orange
as separate objects,
but really in practice,
in unsupervised
learning, I don't
know that these clusters exist.
I would just see
only orange points,
and I'd have to say,
OK, well, these ones
are so close together that I
think they're one grouping.
And these are so close I
think they're one grouping
and these have some
sort of patterns
I think they're one grouping,
but I would never know for sure
if that's right or wrong.
In classification
I'm saying, well,
this is how these two
poin-- or these two groups
are related to each other
given that I have two predictor
variables now, right.
So two inputs.
So here I had a
predictor and response.
Here's two predictor variables.
But within this space of
data that I've collected,
I do actually know that these
points are this grayish color
and these points are
this chartreuse, yellow,
whatever the color this is.
And then I would
just say, OK, great,
I want to classify
this or group these
together and say
that, well, anything
that is within this circle,
I think is a gray point
and otherwise it's you
know the yellow point.
OK.
Now, I'll also say
to you, I'm going
to keep talking about
this supervised learning,
but if this isn't clicking
yet, that is perfectly OK
because I have a literal
whole course dedicated
to this because this is not a
one lecture, kind of, topic, OK.
I've 12 minutes into
this, so you're not
going to be getting this yet.
But if you are
interested, if it's
starting to pique
your interest, I'd
highly recommend considering
first off Data 3300
if you haven't taken that
yet, is a great opportunity.
It's modern data analytics
that will expose you
to a lot of these concepts right
away, kind of a lower level.
And then if you take
Data 5600, from me,
that is a course that dives
deeper into the machine learning
and regression side of
things and gives you
a nice thorough
background on all this.
And then there's actually
also Data 5610/6610,
which is my deep
learning course.
And we'll talk about what
deep learning is in a second.
But first, I wanted to
show you a simple version
of what one of these machine
learning algorithms looks like.
Because before we
said, OK, great,
well, maybe I can fit
a line to the data
and that is simple
enough to understand.
But with decision trees,
these are saying, well,
what if I want to
just fit or find
some sort of natural
grouping right.
Here in this data set over
on the right-hand side
of the screen, we were
looking at trying to predict
baseball player salary, right.
So I think it's on the
order of millions of dollars
at this data set was in.
But either way, you can
see on the horizontal axis
on this plot, I have
the number of years
they were in the league.
And then on the
vertical axis, I have
the number of hits they had.
So how many hits did
they have probably
on average or total for the
season or whatever it is.
It looks like probably total.
I'm not a baseball
fan, so I apologize
if I butcher any of
this explanation,
but it's more just
as an example here.
But either way, you
can kind of imagine
that each one of
these orange points
is an individual player in our
data set, and any one of them
has a known salary value.
But maybe me, I'm
an agent, let's say,
and I'm trying to
say, well, I'm trying
to get a sense of how much
can I expect my client to ask
for in salary in two years.
Well, why not just
use all the data
we have of historical
performances, right.
Know how many years they
would be in the league
for at that point in
time, how many hits
we'd expect them to have,
or given how many hits,
how much could they expect.
So that would be maybe
the motivation there.
And so now I just want to find
some sort of function that
tells me, well, what's this
relationship between years hits
and then the outcome, the
response variable being salary?
So decision trees take a
really clever approach.
Is they say, well, let me look
at these two dimensions, right,
hits and years, these are
dimensions in my data set.
And let me see.
Well, if I draw a line kind of
a vertical or horizontal line
through this data
set, I could choose
either vertical or horizontal
and it could be anywhere
in there but it has to be one
of those directions, which
one of those would
result in the most
similar groupings or the
most similar outcome groups
from this.
And so it turns out
that for this data set,
the number of years is the
first most important thing.
It says any case or any
situation where there are--
or where there is
less than 4.5 years,
or for all those people that
are less than 4.5 years,
those are similar
enough such that I
don't want to split any more.
I can just stop there and
say, OK, for the most part,
anyone less than 4 and
1/2 years on average,
plus or minus some
noise is about 5.11,
I guess a million
for the salary.
So that just tells me maybe
that's rookie contracts, right.
Those early in your career, you
can expect on average, no matter
how many hits you have,
it's just about 5.11.
But after that point, right,
once they're greater than 5.--
or 4.5 years well,
then what matters.
Well, I've kind of
gotten to this group now,
and maybe I could
have stopped there
and just averaged everything
to the right here.
So R1 representing those
that are in the rookie
years or the early
years and then
the veterans falling in
these two regions here.
But I imagine before I've
made this split at R2 and R--
to create R2 and R3, this
is just one big group,
but for whatever
reason, maybe I didn't
feel that this one big group
was homogeneous enough, right.
There was too much
spread in the salaries.
So I decide to split again.
And so then the next best split
that could possibly happen
and it could have
been vertical again,
it could have been horizontal.
This time, though, it
seemed that it was actually
horizontal was the best--
was with hits less than 117.5.
So it seems now that for those
or basically to hit the highest
average salary, you need to not
only be beyond your 4 and 1/2
year mark, but you also need
to get more than 117.5 hits.
This group up here is
homogeneous enough now
to say that, well, if we just go
ahead and average all of those,
the average salary is
about 6.74 and then I
decide not to split anymore.
And the other side
of it is those
that don't have that many hits.
And so they end up
with a lower salary.
It's kind of
intuitively makes sense.
But the nice thing is here
this is a general enough
architecture, a general
enough algorithm,
such that even if I had
1,000 different cate--
or dimensions that I
could look at, right,
maybe it's not just hits,
but it's, you know, rbis,
it's at bats.
It's any number
[INAUDIBLE] right.
What year you were
born, how tall you are,
weight, all these other
characteristics even handedness.
I could have right left
handed where you hit
where you pitch whatever it is.
All those could be different
dimensions I have in my data
set.
And rather than having to
manually go through and figure
out the relationship
between these groups,
this algorithm
will automatically
go through and cut this
data set in such a way
that we end up with the
best prediction possible.
That's, kind of, the
brilliance of machine learning,
is that it's this
structure really,
the learning aspect of it is
that I've created this algorithm
or structured this algorithm in
such a way that it allows my,
you know, my computer here
to just look at the real data
and make the best
choice to define
this correct mapping
or the best mapping
possible between
my inputs, which
is all these dimensions
I'm measuring
about the players themselves,
and then the outputs which
are-- which is the actual salary
that those players received.
And again, I don't have
to do anything manual,
I don't have to go in here
and find patterns myself,
it automatically does that.
And that is, again where the
learning aspect or why people
feel like sometimes this is
artificial intelligence is,
you know, it's finding patterns
amongst massive data sets
that would take me an impossibly
long time to try to do myself.
And it's able to find
those in, you know,
minuscule amounts
of time sometimes.
But as we'll see,
you don't always
have a situation where it's
that fast and a lot of times
it's speed is dependent upon
the computer you're using.
Hint, hint why we
need cloud computing.
So that brings us then-- and
I'll slide a little bit more
out of the way over here.
That brings us then to
this idea of deep learning.
So deep learning is trying to do
a similar thing to what we just
talked about with decision
trees it's just saying,
what if I made this
even more flexible.
What if I kind of expanded
what it could possibly do?
Because here or a better
statement if we go back.
Oops, back.
There we go.
Here it is constrained
in that it can only cut
this way and this way, right.
Every line on this plot was
either vertical or horizontal.
Well, what if the best shape was
actually some weird curvy shape
that separates these groups.
Decision trees can't do that.
And there exists other
algorithms that aren't deep
learning that could do that.
But really what we're getting
at is the more flexible
we make the algorithm, the
more complex of relationships
we can learn.
And deep learning is, kind
of, taking that to the extreme
and saying, well, what if we
create what is arguably the most
general architecture.
I did some work
before in actually
when I was doing my
PhD here at Utah State
on trying to find a
direct mapping actually
between decision trees
and deep learning.
And it turns out, using the
deep learning algorithm,
I can actually recreate
exactly what decision trees do.
That won't make any
sense now, but it's just
to show that for the most part,
these algorithms are typically
doing the same thing,
and they usually
have some sort of
underlying shared structure.
But at a high
level, deep learning
seems to be the most general
approach right now at least.
So to, you know,
distill what is now,
you know, not just
an advanced topic,
but, you know, kind of two
courses, three courses down
the line for you into one slide,
so, again, an impossible task,
but I just want you
to be exposed to it,
at least in case you're curious.
You know, we're still, kind
of, doing the same thing here.
So we have our
input X data, right.
This is our inputs.
And we have our true Y's.
These are our outputs.
These are our
response variables.
Kind of same thing we said.
So predictor variables
and response variables.
Now, the clever thing
is with deep learning
is we do something
kind of iterative.
So what we do is we
establish these layers.
You can think of them, think of
them as transformations, right.
Ways that we can
manipulate the input data.
And the way that
they're manipulated
is actually defined
by these weights.
Funny enough, if you have, you
know, taken an algebra course,
and you remember y
equals mx plus b,
it's actually the same algorithm
or same equation that's
happening under the hood here.
It's a little bit-- there's a
few more m's and a few more b's,
right.
Those are the
parameters of the model
or the weights of
the model, right. m
and b could be
referred to as weights.
But that's basically
what's happening here.
It's just that
we've expanded this
now to allow it to be
arbitrarily many m's and b's,
however many weights that we'd
like to have in the model.
So we put our x data through
this y equals mx plus
b esque type function,
and then that
produces some sort of output.
But rather than that
actually being our y,
that could just be
an intermediate step
and we could take that
and make that, you know,
go through the next layer.
And the next layer after that,
and we could stack as many
of these layers as we wanted
to, each of them having
a unique random set of weights.
And that's the
deep-learning aspect of it,
is there's depth, there's this
depth wise operation that's
happening.
But at the end of
the day, no matter
what happens in this big
black box of weights in here,
the input is x and
the output will still
be some y, some sort
of predicted value.
So again, think of this in the
context of the baseball player
salaries.
I put in all the variables I
know about the baseball players.
I predict their salary.
Well, now what I
can do is I can say,
well, I know what
the true salary
was because it's labeled data.
And so I'll compare the true
salary to the value I predicted.
And what I'll actually
do is I'll just calculate
the mean squared error, right.
The difference.
Think about it this
way, I can just
subtract the true y
from the predicted y
or vice versa, square those
so that the numbers are always
positive, such that a bigger
number means that it's not
as good of a predicted y.
Because if the error
is smaller, that
means even when
I square it, it's
still relatively small number.
That would be a good prediction.
So we want to minimize the
distance between these true wise
and predicted wise.
But either way, I
make my prediction.
I look at the error
between those two.
That's what the loss
function is doing.
The mean squared error
here is my loss function.
And so if it's a big
mean squared error,
that means it's a bad loss.
My loss is large.
If it's a small
mean squared error,
that means it's a
small loss value.
And my goal is to
minimize the loss.
That's what I'm trying
to do is minimize
the error in this model.
And so that's what
the optimizer does,
is the optimizer does a
little bit of calculus in here
and it says, OK,
well, what direction
do I need to move
all the weights
in this model at the same time?
How do I need to adjust
these numbers, these--
I think about that, and that's
that y equals mx plus b.
In what ways do I need to
adjust those m's and b's such
that I reduce the distance
between the true y
and the predicted y.
And I only do a small step.
I don't try to make this in
one jump in one training pass,
I let this be iterative.
So it just takes a little
step here each time.
And then every time
through is trying
to get better and
better and better.
And so given enough data
and enough compute power,
I should conceivably be able
to learn any sort of function,
any mapping between
inputs X and Y's.
It's just a matter of
data and compute power.
And so that's basically
deep learning.
So I guess if you don't want to
take my 5610 class or 5600, that
will get you there.
But I'd imagine there's
probably a little bit more
that you didn't pick up in that.
So there's a lot
more to go with that
but I just want you to
be aware of what this is.
And then also we'll
see-- actually,
we'll try to utilize this some--
or at least start exploring
how we could utilize
this, some leveraging a
lot of these cloud tools.
And this is just,
kind of, a visual,
I guess this is the most math
I'll ever show in this class.
So not any of this am I
expecting you to understand.
But just so you can
again see what's
happening at this lower level.
We have some sort of
inputs or hidden values.
Those go through another layer.
And within one of
these little nodes
here, each of these
little circles are nodes.
This is a deep learning model.
So multilayer perception
feed forward neural network,
deep learning, those are
all saying the same thing,
even though they're
completely different words.
Sorry, that's how we do it.
But the moral of the
story is what we have
here is a function that is z
equals w times a plus w times
a plus w times a plus b.
And each of these w's
and a's are slightly
different from each other.
You see, there's different,
different notations.
But functionally speaking,
that's kind of like y equals mx
plus b.
Now I'm doing a couple
mixes each time through,
because I have different
numbers or different--
I have more than one
predictor variable,
so I'll have as many
X's as I have there.
And I'm using A's
instead of X's.
But that's irrelevant for now.
The moral of the
story is we're just
learning a linear function here
with a nonlinear activation, OK.
I won't worry about that word.
But just note we're introducing
some bit of non-linearity
in here so that it can learn
nonlinear functions too.
I hope I didn't just completely
demystify or mystify you there.
It's not to show you that
it's even more of a black box
than it was before.
It's more to show you that,
like it can be understood a bit.
And I think it's a
really interesting topic,
so I can highly
recommend you all
try to learn more about this.
And again, if you ever want any
sources to start diving into,
I'm happy to give you that.
But from there, I want to
show one more concept that
is actually a bit more general
than just deep learning.
So if I go back here for
a brief, brief second,
we said there's
supervised learning
and there's
unsupervised learning.
Supervised learning is
when I have labels, right.
Predict salary, given
years of education
or predict salary,
given number of hits,
or predict the next
word in a sentence.
Unsupervised learning is saying,
well, I don't know any labels.
I don't know what groups go
together so just find any sort
of patterns that might exist.
There's one more
quirk to all of these,
or I guess third option to--
there's not-- so there's
not just supervised learning
and unsupervised
learning, we also
have something called
reinforcement learning.
And this you might have heard
of in the context of games.
So this is a link here, and
I'll put this up on canvas,
but you can also
search it on YouTube.
It's just a documentary.
It's about AlphaGo.
And so this was a couple
of years back now.
But this was a case where there
was a reinforcement learning
agent, that's what we refer
to these as, that was learning
how to play the game of Go.
Go is in the similar
vein to chess,
it's more of an
area control game
than chess is, though arguably
chess is kind of that as well.
But it has many, many
board combinations, right.
So where chess has on
the order of millions,
potentially even billions of
different board configurations,
Go is on the order, I think
it's like 10 to the 170th power.
It's an unholy amount of
number of board configurations.
So it's not something where I
can find the correct or the best
move possible.
There is a level of learning
or, kind of, you know,
I hate to say the word
intelligence necessary to try
to find the next best move.
Well, reinforcement
learning is an algorithm
that allows us to do that.
And so this documentary is
about this whole process
of training AlphaGo and
what it allowed us to do.
But at a high
level, reinforcement
learning differs from
supervised learning in that
rather than having existing
labeled data instead
I just put my algorithm
into an environment, right.
So let's think about
a game like chess.
That's something
we all know, right.
So let's take a game like chess.
There are-- there's
the space, right.
The state space,
the way the board
is configured, right, where
each position is on the board.
And that changes over time.
So let's just start
out with a board
that's completely, you know,
at the start of the game.
At any point in
time, there's a set
of actions that
can be made, right.
I'm allowed to move
any of my pieces
in a specific predefined way.
And so my question is then, what
reinforcement learning agent has
to do is say, OK, well, what's
the best action to take such
that I maximize the reward.
So I'll have to define
a reward, right.
Maybe a reward is a number of
pieces of opponent's pieces
I've knocked off the board.
Or maybe reward is
just win the game.
Don't win the game.
And so I'll just make
a bunch of random moves
until I get to the
very end of the game.
And that's actually
how they did this.
That's how they trained this.
Is they said, OK,
well, let's just
let two reinforcement learning
agents play against each other,
make random moves, and then,
eventually, one of them
will win, meaning that
some move in there,
some set of moves
in there was better
than what the other one did.
And let's learn from that.
I've now created labeled
data to some extent, right.
The state, the
observation about my space
is the input x and the
output is the action.
Given the input,
state of the board,
predict the next
best action to take.
And the loss
function here is now
trying to actually maximize
the reward function.
So as opposed to
minimizing the loss,
I'm trying to
maximize the reward.
Similar idea though.
This same idea persists
and is used a lot
in training self-driving cars.
Is I can observe the
state of my world, right.
I can collect all the
data from every sensor
that I have in my
car, all the cameras,
lidar, radar, whatever it is.
I can feed that into my
reinforcement learning agent,
which is just a neural network.
And the way we've implemented
them in the modern era.
So I feed all of
those sensors as input
to my reinforcement learning
agent, to my neural network,
and I predict the next
best action, right?
Steer left, steer right.
How much to steer left,
how much to steer right,
accelerate, brake.
That's all part of
my action space.
So I decide the next
best action to take
and then I evaluate that.
I take that action and I see
how good that action was.
And if it got me closer
to my destination
or didn't result in
an accident, however,
I define my reward
function that will be
or that will be, kind of,
what I try to maximize, right.
I'm going to try to maximize
that reward function.
And that's a
non-trivial task also.
So I'm not going
to pretend that is
an easy thing by any means,
because, for example, let's
take the self-driving car case.
If I define my reward function
as getting to my destination,
well then it's likely
going to just break
every rule of the road to just
maximize the reward of getting
to the destination.
Or potentially, I don't
know what's worse,
it'll do the opposite
and just say, well, I'll
drive 1 miles per hour
because at least then I
don't crash into things
and so I will eventually
make it to my destination.
So maybe I say, OK, I'll
penalize you for every second
that you're not at
the destination.
Well, then it will
learn to go faster,
but it'll likely go too fast and
again, break every rule of road,
crash into things and just race.
And it'll find some
balance, probably
between crashing into things
and getting to the destination
but it'll likely be a huge
risk and a huge liability.
And so this question of how
to actually optimize this
or how to define
the reward function
such that the reinforcement
learning agent, the neural net
doesn't find some
sort of shortcut,
that is a really, really
hard research question.
And they talk about this again
a bit in this documentary.
So it's a really
interesting one to watch.
It's for free on YouTube.
I think it's like an hour
and a half, but very popular.
Won a ton of rewards.
So highly recommend that if
you're interested at all.
But yeah, so this kind
of gives us another realm
of things we can do.
And one of the main reasons I
actually want to show you this
is because this is something
that AWS has been really
heavily behind.
For that matter, I kind of have
it sitting next to me over here.
Let's see if I can pull it up
on the internet really quick.
So Amazon built this tool here.
Now I can't see my screen.
Let's go with our--
here we go.
So this is the AWS
DeepRacer, and I actually
have one right here.
This is the shell for it.
And the body, the computer
of it is taken apart from it
right now.
So this is what's sitting
underneath all of the components
right there.
But you can see the front
end a little bit here.
This is where the cameras
technically plug into,
but they're all
disconnected right now.
I was playing with
something else, so sorry,
it's not working.
I was to show it or do a
demo if it was working.
But either way,
this is something
that Amazon put forth
not only to teach people
how self-driving cars work,
but also to push their services
and give you a way to play
around with their tools.
So they train-- or they--
if you purchase this,
you can use your
free-tiered Amazon
account to train
a self-driving car
or train this little
self-driving car
in a simulator on AWS, like on
an EC2 instance, doing that,
and then you can deploy it and
actually run it on real track.
So they have a league
and all kinds of things.
So there's some really
cool tools out there.
So you can see this is
a fully built out one,
and this is actually their
second generation, which
has a LiDAR sensor
and a second camera.
My version just has one
camera and no LiDAR.
But either way, Amazon
has put a lot of effort
behind these tools--
where's my-- I'll
close my slides,
open these back up again.
But Amazon has put
a lot of effort
behind these tools for
reinforcement learning.
And so really,
really cool topic.
Again, if you're
interested at all,
happy to chat
about it some more.
But yeah, that's what
we got going so far.
So now how does this intersect
with cloud computing.
That's kind of the
big question then.
And I, you know, this is kind
of my best guess as to how
I would say it
intersects, but I think
it covers the bases
because it really
presents-- or cloud
computing presents
a benefit in a couple
of different areas.
And that's data collection,
data labeling, the development
of these models, right, the
actual training of these models,
and then the deployment of them.
So to take those piece
by piece, let's start
with data collection.
And this is, you know, the
kind of unsung hero of machine
learning, because if I don't
have good labeled data,
I'm not going to
have good results.
As we talked about, we use
those real labeled data
points to find a mapping
between inputs and outputs.
And so AWS is a great,
great tool for this.
So this example here above
is from my dissertation work.
So for this work, I was trying
to and I cannot remember if I
explained this to you all,
so I apologize if I have.
But at a high level, at
least what I was trying to do
is I was trying to say, well,
there exists a lot of satellite
imagery of the world.
And actually, to some
extent, satellite
imagery some of the
easiest we can get, right.
If there's a natural disaster,
it's probably pretty hard
to get somebody on the
ground to that location
or if there's a wildfire
that comes through.
But it's not impossible to
get a satellite overhead.
And actually, for that matter,
there's likely going to be
a satellite overhead on the
order of like 90ish minutes
to a couple hours.
And so I can get a great
view from an overhead
of what it looks like.
But that doesn't always tell
me the whole story of what
it looks like on the ground.
There's a reason we use Google
Street View as much as we do.
Now the problem is, is again,
street view, first off,
doesn't exist for
everywhere on the globe
and second, it
doesn't update, right.
Once they've taken
that image, it
might be years, if not
decades, before they ever
decide to update it up again.
My house on Google Street View
looks completely different
than it does right now.
And so what we wanted to do
is we wanted to see, well,
could I train a
machine learning model
that, given as input the
satellite image and maybe also
a description of what it looks
like on the ground there,
predict what it actually
looks like on the ground.
And so to do that,
I needed data.
I needed labeled data to do
this and I needed a lot of data.
So, you know, it's not
something where I can just
go out and find three
images or go to Google Earth
and take some screenshots, I
need on the order of thousands,
if not millions.
Unfortunately, we didn't
have the order of millions,
but we ended up with a few
tens of thousands of images.
So on the right hand
side here, which
you can see this is actually a
map of all the satellite images
I had.
So I was working for
a company that had--
that was a satellite
imagery company, right.
So I was working for Maxar.
And so we had at least
first party access
to satellite images.
Each one of these
yellowish strips
here is actually
a satellite image.
So the it takes the
picture is, kind of,
almost like a panned
shot right over the top.
And so there's these
long, you know,
few hundred kilometer strips
of images that you have.
And then we crop
out little regions
that because these are
such big images, but really
high resolution.
So on the order of 30
centimeters per pixel.
So you can see anything that's
about down to that scale, right.
You know, if you imagine
30 centimeters by 30cm,
if there's some object
that's that size,
it would just show
up as one pixel.
So we had this.
We could get that and
that was organized.
And granted, we use a little
bit of cloud computing
to store this because
it was so much imagery,
each of these
images being usually
on the order of a
gigabyte or two per them.
But these images on
the left hand side
were the Street
View ones, because I
needed some sort of Street
View to train this on.
Is if I wanted to be able
to predict from a satellite
image what it looks
like on the ground,
I need to have labeled examples.
And so this is a website
that they've actually
changed their ownership
now so I forget
what the name is now but at the
time, it was open street Cam.
So it was an open source data
set or open source website
where users could just go on and
upload images from their dash
Cam or the cell phone
that they had sitting
on the dash, whatever it was.
And it'll have the
associated Lat long,
you know, the heading
where they were going
and all that stuff, the
direction they were going.
And so you could click on any
one of these-- every little one
of these purple dots.
There's actually a bunch
of little dots in there.
Every one of these
purple dots is an image
because if you imagine
if somebody's driving
and it's taking
video, you know, even
if it's sampling only
one every few seconds,
there's a lot of images.
And so there was a ton
of these images online,
but they didn't have
some sort of simple API
where I could just
go grab them all.
So I needed to actually
crawl through and download
each one of these images.
And to avoid overwhelming
their servers
and also automate
this on my side
so I don't have to eat up my
computer, we leveraged AWS.
And so we'll talk
about AWS Lambda next.
But AWS Lambda is
a tool that allows
us to do exactly this, right.
So I defined a function that
said, hey, download this image.
And maybe I had-- and I had a
path for basically saying, OK,
I'll give you this latitude
and longitude, based off
of the satellite image I have.
Go download the
closest image to that.
And so that's
exactly what it did.
And AWS Lambda is, is
a completely serverless
compute platform, which
we'll talk about plenty.
But a serverless compute
platform in that sense
that I don't have to
spin up an EC2 instance,
I just say, hey, run this
function on a schedule
or based off a triggered
event or whatever it is,
and do this task that I have.
And so you can just set this
up, download all these images,
push them to S3 and now you
have all your images downloaded.
Don't have to eat up any
of your compute resources
and you only pay
for however many
computations you end up doing.
So this is one way,
one of many, many ways
that we can leverage
AWS for data collection.
So we'll talk about
Lambda in this sense.
Then from a labeling side,
we won't really do this,
I don't think but it's still
a very valuable skill or thing
to recognize that
we can do in here,
and that's the actual
labeling of it.
So in my case, that was
actually already labeled right.
Once I had the location,
that was exactly the label.
But maybe I've collected or
downloaded a bunch of images,
and I want to go through and
I'm training a self-driving car
and so I want to know
what's in the image.
Well, unfortunately,
there's no shortcut
to this other than having
a human go in there
and say, OK, well, this is
a car, this is a handbag,
this is a purse, and
this is a traffic light
and manually label each
one of these points,
draw a bounding
box around it, too.
And this is how it's done.
It takes many,
many hours, if not
years of, or-- human
years of effort
to label some of these
massive data sets.
But one way you can scale this
is by using cloud resources.
And one of the more
interesting cloud tools,
if you haven't
heard of it before,
is Amazon's Mechanical Turk.
This is an online on demand
24/7 platform that you can go
on and say, hey, I have
a stack of images, right.
I have a stack of million images
and I'll pay fractions of a cent
or a few cents per labeled
image, right per image
that people go in
here and label.
And then I'll just put it out
there for the world to do.
And, you know, give an
economies of scale here,
right, I have enough
people on this platform
that if they go
through here and click
a few hundred or a
few thousand of these
takes a amount of time for
them but they can balance that.
They can weigh that value of
them going through and manually
labeling that versus not.
And so this is one way
that companies heavily
leverage the cloud.
And it's not even,
again, a cloud,
you know, computer,
it's just humans
sharing information and
sharing knowledge and resources
through the cloud.
Human resource, right.
Like human capital.
So this is a super-valuable
tool for machine learning.
And I mean, honestly,
couldn't be valued enough.
There's other platforms
for it but Mechanical Turk
is probably the most famous.
And, you know, there's all
kinds of other things too.
It's not just, you
know, labeling data
for machine learning, but
it is one of the biggest use
cases for it.
Then on to the actual
model development side.
So this is actually when I'm
getting to my deep learning
models and I need to
physically train those things.
As we talked about, the
number of computations
necessary to do that can be
incomprehensibly large, right.
For some of these
models, like again,
we talked about these weights,
the number of weights.
Well, if I'm doing y equals mx
plus b, there's really one way.
There's one m
value, maybe the b,
if you count that you'll give--
I'll give you two weights
that you have to learn.
For the largest
models today, you're
usually on the order of a few
trillion parameters, right.
Trillion with a T.
Even for the models that I was
training, which is actually--
this was my computer that
I was training them on,
this was at my house, that
was on the order of millions
of parameters still.
And you know, this was having
to run for days on end.
I wouldn't have been able
to afford this computer
if I wasn't doing
this for a company.
I mean, this computer alone
was probably on the order
of $10,000.
I mean, for example,
this GPU that you
see on the top that
was a Titan RTX.
At the time, that was $2,500.
That was pre-pandemic.
When the pandemic hit and then
we had crypto boom happening,
paired with everybody being
at home and wanting to gain,
paired with machine learning
continuing to be a need,
these skyrocketed.
And so after like three
years of having it,
its value was up to
around $5,000 or $6,000.
So that fluctuation
in market value
can be a huge burden on
companies doing machine
learning research.
But either way, an
absolute necessity
to have this massive
compute power.
And that's the reason
the cloud has become
so valuable for
machine learning,
at least, is because I can
scale up to any size of computer
at any point in
time, and I don't
need to buy all of this hardware
upfront and maintain it, right.
This was sitting in my room
getting dusty, needing updates
constantly.
I mean, it was a hassle
to keep take care of.
Not to mention also it was
just drawing a ton of energy
at my house.
You know, I was paying that
electricity bill, generating
a ton of heat in my
house, which was actually
nice in the winter time.
I used it as a foot warmer.
But, you know, not winter time.
That's not ideal.
Now I have to pay
more energy to cool
this room so it doesn't overheat
and it can run at full capacity.
Leveraging the cloud, I wouldn't
have to worry about that at all.
What you see on
the right over here
actually is Google's, right.
So this is a plug for
Google because they're kind
of leading the game in this.
Amazon does have access to
a massive number of GPUs
and they have a bunch of
GPUs at their data centers
that you can put
on EC2 instances
but this is a custom built
chip specifically designed
for machine learning.
It's called a tensor
processing unit.
So TPU as opposed to GPU.
And these are the most efficient
compute chips today, right,
for neural networks or for
machine learning specifically.
And I think the last
time I looked-- it's
been a while since I've looked.
They're usually on the order
of a couple dollars per hour
to reserve.
And for some of
the larger projects
you might need still on the
order of hundreds or thousands
of these at a time.
So it still can be very,
very expensive per hour
but they're so
efficient that you
don't need to train for as
long and so they can save you
money in the long run.
And so this is again by far why
I've used the cloud the most,
is just to leverage cloud
resources for training machine
learning models.
Because I can now use my laptop.
Don't ever have
to worry about it.
I don't care what my laptop does
or what kind of laptop it is.
Because the second I
need to train a model,
I'm going to spin
up an EC2 instance.
I'm going to add a
bunch of GPUs to it,
and I'm going to do
all my training there,
and then I'm only going to
return my results to my laptop.
So no matter what
device I'm on, no matter
where I'm at in the world, I'll
always have, kind of, high end
compute power.
And the fact that I can
spin up a supercomputer
in a matter of seconds
on an EC2 instance
is, again, one of
those things that
puts us so far ahead of where
we used to be in this space.
And then finally, the
last side of things.
And this one, you,
kind of, we'll
touch less because there's
not a real good hands on way
to show it.
But we've seen it actually,
to some extent, in the model--
with model deployment.
Because at some point
I've trained the model,
I have this model
that can now detect
whether it's a cat or a dog.
Great.
That's a fun tool
to have in isolation
but maybe I need to put this out
into the world for other users
to use, right.
Maybe I'm Netflix and I'm using
machine learning to recommend
the next best movie to you.
I need to deploy that
feature in some way, right.
That recommended filtering.
And there's a couple of
ways I could do that, right.
I can do a web app or an API
like we've been doing, right.
I could put a machine-learning
model on the back end of my API
that we've seen how to
build out because we already
have it in Python.
So as long as I have
an EC2 instance that
has the code and the weights and
the models loaded onto there,
it's actually the same as
what we already have built.
So you could build one today
using exactly those steps.
The other way I could deploy
it is using an edge device.
So maybe I have something
that is maybe a fruit quality
detector, right.
It detects whether a tomato is
good or bad as it's coming down
my assembly line.
And maybe I don't
have the time to wait
for it to go all the way
from the side of my factory,
all the way out to Amazon's, you
know, data center and US West
to my specific EC2 instance,
to make that prediction,
I need to have it happen
as fast as possible.
So I could either use AWS's
global presence, right.
The fact that they have
these edge locations where
I could just send it to an
edge or a regional cache
to either store the
information or maybe
do some sort of inference
if they have the resources
at that regional location
or that edge location.
Or even it might
be something where
I do all my model
training in the cloud
and then push updates
to my edge devices.
And so these two things
here on the right
are actually small
little computers
that are specifically
designed to make predictions
for machine learning models.
So they're not fully
built out big GPUs,
they're kind of smaller
devices that have one purpose,
and that's just to
make predictions.
And I can put this physically
on my machine, my factory,
and it just makes
the predictions
right there as fast as it can.
But it communicates
up with the cloud.
It sends data back and
forth and all that stuff
but the prediction can
still be made on device.
Or, kind of, the last
way you'll see this
is actually leveraging
the Lambda functions.
So just as we saw bef-- or as I
was talking about before where
I could use lambda
function to collect data,
I could also use them
to make predictions.
Such that if somebody sends in
data or uploads data to my API,
right, they'd be pushed data
to my S3 bucket in some way.
They have an Upload
button on my web app
and they send data
to my S3 bucket.
Well, I can have that S3
bucket having a new file
added trigger an event that
kicks off a AWS Lambda function.
And that lambda function
maybe runs my model
that makes a prediction
of what's in the image
and sends that information
back to the user, right.
So I can have this
all pipe together.
Just leveraging cloud tools,
never stepping out of the cloud
and having a seamless,
scalable experience.
And again, that is I think,
the real power and weight
of being able to leverage the--
you know, the cloud
for machine learning.
So that's it for my
thoughts on this.
I'll say again-- you know,
kind of go back full screen--
I'll say again that we're
going to talk about a few
more examples of how
to do this directly.
And by no means, just as
with the web app development,
are we going to cover everything
or even close to everything.
We're just going to introduce
these ideas and these topics,
and I hope that it's at least
enough motivation for you
to try to pursue this further.
You'll see, again, me leverage
cloud tools in machine learning
classes in the future.
So if you take one
of those classes,
you're definitely still
be using the cloud.
You'll just now
know why and what's
going on behind the scenes.
So we'll leave it
at that for now.
It's already running
a little bit long.
I figured this
would be the topic
that I could rant
on for way too long,
so I'll try to keep
it short and then
I'll keep the next video a
little bit shorter as well too
so we can just get into
the weeds of it, OK.
So I'll see you next time.